welcome back to cbs morning's johnny
depp testified under oath for four days
that he never hit his ex-wife amber
heard now she is telling the same court
that he was lying heard testified in
great detail yesterday about depp's
alleged physical abuse depp is suing her
for 50 million dollars because he claims
she ruined his career by going public
and describing herself as a domestic
abuse survivor hurd is countersuing
depth for 100 million dollars she claims
his lawyers falsely accused her of
making up claims against him carter
evans has the latest from the courtroom
we warn you that her's testimony
includes graphic accounts of alleged
abuse
he felt like he was on top of me and i'm
look i'm looking at him in his eyes
and i don't see him anymore
i don't see him anymore it wasn't him it
was black
i've never been
so scared in my life sobbing through her
second day of testimony amber heard
described johnny depp's alleged attacks
in graphic detail my head was bashing
against the back of the bar and i
couldn't breathe she accused depp of
slapping and kicking her during a
private flight with others no one did
anything
i felt so embarrassed that he could kick
me to the ground
in front of people and heard broke down
while claiming that during an
alcohol-fueled rage in australia depp
sexually assaulted her
her lawyers then showed images she took
of the trashed home from that trip
including bloodstains there was blood
on the carpet
i could see blood drips
my
forearms were cut
my bottoms and my feet were sliced up
pretty good for cbs mornings i'm carter
evans
and cbs news legal analyst ricky clement
joins us now ricky we've covered stories
in the same wheelhouse before when you
look at what this case is about jurors
need to be convinced
that johnny depp
did not physically abuse amber hurd when
you listen to the testimony over these
last couple of days what do you make of
what amber hurt has had to say thus far
jurors will always have their own
opinions so you're going to have some
jurors there is no doubt who are going
to be dramatically moved by amber
heard's testimony because it's not only
the graphic details she has but it's
also backed up by photographs by text
messages
the photographs of the bruises
themselves so how does another juror
who's skeptical about her testimony
argue with the first juror well that
juror says she's an actress
this is something that she does for a
living this is to quote johnny depp's
lawyers this is the performance of her
life but the only way for that juror to
be able to say how she got those
horrendous bruises
is to say well she hit him he defended
himself
well that's maybe a stretch for many a
juror her testimony was very very
powerful because of what backed it up
when you talk about the performance of a
life that came from johnny depp's team
and then you had statements that were
also released by heard where she said
that you know if you're truly innocent
then you wouldn't have promised to quote
put the monster away she talked about
the libel case in the uk
the restraining order that was granted
when they divorced
why do you think they released those
statements what was the legal strategy
there both sides really needed to
release statements because you are now
going to have a 10-day break which is
almost unheard of in any case so you
have jurors who are going home and the
last thing that they have heard is amber
heard in agonizing testimony or on the
other hand in acting testimony but if
it's agonizing testimony johnny depp
needed to go forward and really make a
statement and then she needed to respond
blaming not only depp
for
absolutely not taking responsibility but
blaming zepp's lawyers as well so ricky
at the end of this the the the jury is
going to rule simply on that question
edrica mentioned did johnny depp abuse
amber heard or is there a bigger ruling
well there's a bigger ruling involved
because what the jury is really being
told is were the statements of amber
heard proved by johnny depp's side
to be
done with malice meaning that they were
false
so we have to believe in order for
johnny depp to collect anything that
johnny depp has proven by clear and
convincing evidence that she has lied
it's a very high burden only in the
op-ed is the question because they've
made all these other claims right that
outside of the court context you would
think would be defamation lawsuits in
their own right that is correct but the
op-ed is the only thing that we are
considering here because as johnny
depp's witnesses put forth the op-ed was
in the washington post right and he says
it lost him money and work well and i
think on that score
whatever lost him money and work the
damages are proven the question is were
they caused by amber opera right all
right ricky kliman thank you as always
for coming in